good morning ladies and gentlemen we are
about to begin boarding South Northern
Airlines flight 34 to Grand Rapids
Mississippi
I'm in boarding group one
and we would like to begin pre-boarding
with our first class passengers
first-class passengers only please
next are business class passengers may
now board
okay now we would like to welcome our
Regal Alliance Elite members Regal
Alliance Elite members
okay now all passengers with children
anyone with small children you mean
bored now
okay we would like to continue boarding
with uniformed military personnel what
why kids this is
thank you for your service thank you so
much for your service God bless you
thank you for your service thank you for
your service
all right people in wheelchairs
any priests nuns rabbis imans what why
do they get special treatment assalamu
alaikum I've never
that's typical any old people in
wheelchairs with babies
any old religious people with military
babies what's a military
thank you for your service
Jason Schwartzman
anyone with a blue suitcase you may now
board finally no not you sir not me this
is a blue suitcase that's a blue
computer bag so you're not you're not
gonna let me on then
God damn it
anyone who doesn't seem cranky
are people who will now be boarding any
drunk people
drunk people
no it's my bag sir
oh
hello
oh hey Christian
yeah
totally
well you have your favorites and I have
my favorites
okay
call you later
boarding group one
[Music]
[Applause]
I got it
I got your experience everyone
[Music]
thank you
we've got Jason Statham to let you wrap
it up people
morning room one over here
get a buddy group one ah